hey guys Orion right here and Randy
fries found out she's into video games
so I found someone to watch the
Assassin's Creed unity story trailer
with now I don't know what the story is
do you know I don't what a genuine
reaction we are going to have I'm I'm
kind of excited let's just watch it we
should watch it yeah okay here we go you
ready Randy yeah blood and gore intense
violent sexual theme strong language and
use of alcohol dude this sounds awesome
I know it's getting into it already
create and furniture Napoleon certainly
don't look like a blood-crazed
revolutionary you know good is a bit
sinister though if you don't mind my
saying it is sometimes hard to remember
how easy life was before the world
changed
now people are starving in the streets
and those with the will to fight back
are imprisoned or worse where am I you
know we showed you two nothing but they
enhance the life I had is gone your
father was an assassin earner the world
I knew with it gives life fight for the
liberty of all mankind are you prepared
to travel the Eagles path always ready
amongst the violence vote is cast red
Laster or done amongst the chaos body as
far as memory I will find justice no
matter the cost
this is why I joined the Brotherhood for
them full Redemption mr. Maximillion
again I will never
if Jesus
you used we use one another
you're the only one who can save the
Brotherhood
it happens tonight please want to
protect me
to help you
nicely done my friend
you don't have the stomach for revenge
then I don't need your help we've been
betrayed from within Spurs team I have
to do this myself
apparently feels like fake history that
looks epic
oh really doesn't look Philip that looks
pretty [ __ ] sweet I just love the
story behind it okay not one thing that
I really love about a lot Assassin's
Creed just in general is that
authenticity of the time period in which
it's set like it's so cool like um the
weaponry the I'm just all of it so cool
no they even have like pretty good
writing for the most part just an actual
semantics I think it's pretty good too
oh yeah I think it's really great this
this is just such a cool like historical
fiction type of tale and I I'm I'm just
jacked up to be that guy when I'm using
the controller I just want to be him
live vicariously but that's what think
it gave one of the vicariously yeah I
want to play the game but Assassin's
Creed is uh the like damn what is like
the seventh game or something is it
there's like a lot of these on whatever
doesn't matter I'm sure an act like I
know a bunch of things I don't mean I
think this is maybe the fourth one no no
there's no way more are you sure yeah
crazy I know maybe I'm slacking dude
I'm contemplating whether or not I
should keep that in the video so people
don't judge you probably will you know
guys are back me jiggly jelly jiggly
jelly that's a shout-out you should
appreciate that oh you know what else is
really cool about Assassin's Creed I
think it really made parkour like a big
thing wait assassins cremated big cuz I
know there's like a lot of parkour again
it's nothing yeah no I think it did like
when it first came out they're like oh
man is it really cool just like when you
watch Bourne Identity mm-hmm and you're
Crom with gods like the huge thing in
Bourne Identity
and then Assassin's Creed has like a
bunch of parkour stuff and everyone and
I think after each one that's when the
movements are really happening
oh no interesting
really interesting actually brandy good
movie facts I don't know if it's really
true it's just what I think
no no Brandi you're onto something good
for you oh thank you guys to recommend
you that trailer I've seen a lot of
shows and it's cool to finally see one
that really makes it all clear for me so
for your the shadow to the new shadow
memory subscribe what is it is theater
brandy starting up a YouTube page she
already has the account setting up
subscribe that way you'll get notified
when our new videos are out the doctor
Pete hey right can I get a shout out man
by the way I love the real rejects
you're really funny
any tips to a fellow youtuber who isn't
really good at commentating well first
tip get a little bit better at
commenting yes that's so generic it's
like giving actor direction they're like
just do it again but do it better that
that is what I'm trying to tell them no
okay you're that's that's not anything
constrict okay first off you gotta just
accept yourself that's that's a good
that's nothing [ __ ] yeah there I would
if I'm gonna get a genuine answer
accept yourself don't give a [ __ ] what
anyone else thinks about you yet this is
gonna be [ __ ] out there and once
you like let go of that then it's easier
to just say what you want to say that's
I'm able to talk about you know dick and
con all the time hey talk about the the
[ __ ] in you tell me about it here I'm
talking about the gun thing I was just
seeing that my friend came up with this
game called cut punching and well
actually I don't think she came up with
it she was on set somewhere and she
comes back and it's my birthday and
she's like punching me in the [ __ ] and
my coma sore and it was the one it was
just a terrible experience I don't know
why she's telling me not giving a [ __ ]
what we're talking about we just talked
about it that's the best advice you can
get
don't talk about constants like I mean I
guess you could know maybe was about con
super like damn he's wrong
he's really cool he's real he's like a
rapper man like mocking everyone who
said those things about me
Cameron Adams hey Ryan can I get a shout
out Cameron Adams I'm giving you a
shout-out
oh look for it Alexander de rozier hey
Ryan I've been a huge fan since like
forever dude oh and since I'm here can I
get a shout-out
yes Alexander de rozier I will give you
a shout-out I think it would be cool if
we could say his name like French de
Rossi a Josie a Dora say le a moon no
yeah that's my French accent I would
like to buy a hamburger I think of the
Pink Panther not the original remake
Steve Martin I was I think of Beauty and
the Beast I thought the crab from Little
Mermaid was French what that I realized
he was Jamaican when I was like way
older well that just goes to show you
how stupid Brian is anyway back to you
Alexandre de rozier you should be good
Alexander destroyer you know why what
these are just think if you stay here to
say it and it's it's it just sounds
cooler man it's like BAM the destroyer
like I know what's funny [ __ ] with it
exactly you give yourself that nickname
and then people like do you think people
call him the destroyer know what's gonna
want to [ __ ] with you no one especially
if you know like conch foo yeah junior
vendas sup rang I want to know how often
do you get a haircut because it's been a
while since you got one I recently got
one if you answer to this question can i
get a shoutout pls sub since four
thousand subs wow we've really come a
lot of ways since four thousand now
we're past thirty six thousand subs in
the reason why cuz we're just so awesome
like we're so cool it just makes sense
that thousands of people would like us
so yeah Gina Valdez that's why I don't
really give a [ __ ] to cut my hair I'm
like the subs are still gonna be rolling
in it and it means excessive right I
already know that I have a lot of pride
when I pride myself in the fact of how I
have a lot of pride gay pride which I
actually do have I am gay pride and I
have I also have lesbian pride oh well
that's all encompassing I feel like I
know it's not technically like a PC
thing but I just feel like it's
all-encompassing it is gays and I'm
lesbian - that doesn't make any sense
you know uh this does turn terrible this
turn terrible just turned horrible
what's our hormonal ease I get about hey
guys I've learned enable brob to agree
yes yes yeah but then I realize I don't
know what I'm agreeing to right now look
at it terrible
oh I don't know like it just feels like
that's just a weird place to end
you